[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is opening up about
motherhood there's a million different
emotions that are going on in my brain
the star got candid on her app sharing
what she's learned since giving birth to
daughter true in April quote I think
what surprises me most is no matter how
tired you are you find this energy and
patience for your child the new mama
also gave fans a sneak peek at her
little girls nursery writing quote it's
feminine but still cool adding that
she's been leaning on her sister Kim she
was my angel during pregnancy and has
been so helpful and encouraging we are
similar moms and have been two peas in a
pod lately now Coco is working on her
fitness five weeks after babies and
enjoyed my muscleman right listen I
raised a real thing it's still under
there documenting her goals on snapchat
while Chloe is getting back to her old
self the official status of her
relationship with Tristan seems unknown
after reports surfaced days before the
birth of their daughter that he was
allegedly cheating on her but a source
tells ET that Chloe is planning on
staying in Cleveland where the NBA star
plays for the Cavaliers for another
month quote she's really enjoying this
quality time with her daughter and
Tristan without all the distractions
that come with being in LA surrounded by
so many other people I'm gonna figure it
all out I promise you